34 artistes pour une confrontation tout
en harmonie au sommet la création
contemporaine et des vestiges de
l'histoire réunionnaise
on déambule en verre de l'île à travers
un résumé des images du 19e siècle nos
jours sous les nuages imaginé par kid
créole et boudy voilà que surgit sainte
et speedy c'était une pièce que j'ai
fabriqué en 2009
c'est une interprétation d'une chapelle
sainte expédie voilà qui est fait tout
en cire avec une particularité à
l'intérieur c'était pour une expo qui
s'appelait protection rapprochée en 2009
qui concernait les filets de la route en
corniche
donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya les petites
voitures et ça parle un petit peu de la
cosmogonie de la réunion jean claude
joly nous propose une traduction
personnelle de son de ses peurs de ses
croyances
à quelques pas ce sont trois tableaux
dans peintre autodidacte patrick non
thèse qui s'expose pour la première fois
dans un musée accrocher jusqu alors dans
l'ashram du port les divinités de la
religion hindoue s'invente un nouvel
univers empreint de symboles pour ceux
qui savent les décoder son égide tout
juste diplômé des beaux-arts à mémoriser
chaque détail de ces trois heures j'ai
fait un travail qui m'a beaucoup tenu à
coeur c'est un travail dommage aussi
quelque part un peintre qui m'a beaucoup
touché
depuis que je suis tout petit c'est le
peintre dont j'ai vu les peintures en
premier et toutes les peintures qui sont
dernièrement ils s'appellent patrick
nantaise c'est un peintre qui a été
beaucoup touchées par l'hindouisme
il n'était pas du tout de cette
confession là à la base et il s'est
beaucoup intéressé à cette philosophie à
cet art de vivre à cette façon de
s'exprimer aussi c'est grâce à sam j
aujourd'hui qui nous a contactés pour
aujourd'hui
et puis viennent les questions
existentielles d'abel techer un corps nu
qui cachent parfois sa féminité
et puis ce corps qui acceptent d'être
l'autre est question du paraître et des
codes de la société surgissent mais
l'art ne s'embarrasse pas de préjugés
abel et ses autoportraits font tomber
les masques
c'est aussi une idée de déjà de mettre à
nu d'oublier le vêtement qui est qui est
lourd encore justement et et voilà de
questionner aussi justement ce corps
masculin féminin dans sa nudité le corps
que j'ai tiqué masculin dont je peux pas
faire abstraction et aussi de
questionner justement cette stabilité
qu'on attend c'est c'est pas qu'une
question de d'apparence quoique ça mais
c'est vraiment c'est la personnalité en
fait c'est s'est joué sur ce jeu de rôle
c'est vraiment dur un jeu de rôle en
fait de nous montrer cette cette
ambiguïté là et puis l'exposition
orchestrée par bernard leveneur et
nathalie gonthier abords de la question
de cette île à l'envers où l'on retrouve
parfois des personnes hors du temps ici
ce sont des marginaux qui ont choisi la
rue comme exutoire des laissés pour
contre qui retiennent le regard c'est le
travail de laurent zitte qui capture
avec son objectif les sans domicile fixe
photos sont réalisées à un lieu qui
s'appelle la boutique solidarité à saint
denis et à chaque photo du bois chaque
photo est une rencontre avec un
accueilli de la boutique et c'est une
proposition que nous faisons qu en fait
finalement 2
de se cacher derrière un objet pour être
précis c'est à dire un cahier l'objet
selon eux qui a plus de valeur que ou
qui selon eux qui est nécessaire chez
eux et souvent ça qu'on construit donc
une image ou l'objet l'individu
disparaît dès à l'objet le musée léon
dierx invite à voir autrement notre île
mais il nous invite avant tout à nous
questionner sur la place de l'art dans
la société contemporaine sculpture
peinture photo des supports qui
racontent qu'ils expliquent éveiller la
conscience et qui parfois nous oblige à
ne rien dire rien penser et nous laisser
aller à l'évidence d'une société qui
n'est pas figé et qui ancre beaucoup à
apprendre de l'art